i feel like for a long time i felt like
a rapper who put words over beats and
now i feel like just
working on music and like trying to
learn chords on the piano and just like
trying to understand melody more i feel
way more like a musician now than i ever
have as though you feel me now i'm like
i like feeling starting to like learn i
mean at the end of the day you everyone
gets better bro everyone understands
music more because like you said you
could anybody like like not anybody can
rap like you but anybody can record
lyrics over a beat exactly but there's
so much more musically you know that you
got to get to really you know the exact
same thing exactly and i just feel like
i needed to sit down for a while to
fully understand like and just
appreciate music like i wasn't putting
on music the way i do now like before
i'd be like i'm in music all day bro i'm
sick of it i'm gonna put on a podcast or
something i don't wanna hear music but
now i wake up like excited to like
listen to what do you listen like what
do you listen to like
like set it over yeah i mean just like
because i i feel like sometimes there's
like a fine line between i can't even
lie and say that it was someone else's
music that made me like fall in love
with it it was really just like
appreciating my own music i think we
made like dead prezzies and crossfaded
like those are like some of the first
songs we made for the album so it was
like or like maybe not crossfit but
anyways like some of the like the
singles were the first songs we made for
the album so it was like oh [ __ ] these
are way better than anything i've ever
done
how can i keep making these ones again
and in the process of like just making a
million songs is what made me fall in
love with music